يوم الاحد على ملعب لوسيل تنطلق الصافره
للمره الاخيره في مونديال قطر 20 22
النهائي يجمع بين الارجنتين وفرنسا
المنتخبان يطاردان النجمه الثالثه اخر
بطوله حققتها الارجنتين كانت منذ 36 عاما
ورفعها الاسطوره الراحله مارادونا بينما
فرنسا توجت في نسخه الماضيه هي رابع
مواجهه تجمع الفريقين في بطوله كاس العالم
المره الاولى كانت في اول نسخه عام
1930 والاخيره في مونديال روسيا الماضي
وتحديدا في دور 16 انتهت المباراه وقتها
بفوز فرنسا باربعه اهداف مقابل ثلاثه
وكانت احد امتع مباريات البطوله ميسي لا
يزال يمني النفس باللقب الاغلى وقد قاربت
مسيرته على الانتهاء بينما باقي نجم فرنسا
يسعى للتجويد تتويج بالكاس المره الثانيه
على التوالي قبل عيد ميلاده الرابع
والعشرين فبين ام بابي ومسي سباق اخر على
الحذاء الذهبي في البطوله حيث كلا النجمين
يا مكان خمسه اهداف في تلك النسخه